je suis important revenu fiscal déclaré
revenus alors l'avantagé que j'ai 51 ans
mais ça je suis sympa chinois
c'est un symbole et un peu là à 51 ans
on ne voit plus de près on ne voit plus
de loin je suis et presbytes et mieux
que je ne connais pas les chiffres mais
c'est pas grave je n'ai pas posé la
question à 49 ans j'aurais pu très bien
oui et là malheureusement va passer
entre demi après voilà c'est pas grave
japon
italie fabio fognini
6 mois vous emmener dans les backrooms
j'ai même parlé fort parce que c'est
assez flippant
et regarder en plus il faut compter sans
les faits à sa soeur qui se parer d'un
but
d'avancé mais j'ai pas trop m'aventurer
puisqu'il faut que je trouve une issue
je vais encore
me demandez pas pourquoi je porte le
chapeau tout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'essaie de faire un backflip pour
un projet
et savoir ce que tu cherches j'espère
que tu cherches pas ta beauté parce que
je t'arrête tout de suite tu peux te
relever tu vas pas l'autre
je cherche mes lunettes
je peux voir pourquoi tu aurait perdu
tes lunettes ici
tiens prends tu veux prendre
qu'est ce que je pense de secrets
d'histoire alors justement pendant ce
mois
non je parlais de 2,2 me tue c'est
lorànt deutsch qui fait les émissions de
radio allongez vous
retrouvez nous en fin d'année dans
laissez vous guider sur france 2 voilà
est plutôt ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]